this first kick starts a game and the
first ballot cast by an estimated 5
million young voters they're expected to
play a major role in determining turkey
as feature in tight presidential and
Parliament elections on May 14.
none of them have known any leadership
other than that of President reject
erdogan and his governing party Mustafa
Kemal would have voted for Muharram
ninja if he hadn't pulled out of the
race
the economy is terrible this government
needs to change they've been in power
for so many years now I think he can fix
the problems especially the education
and economy it should seem the migrants
back to their countries according to one
survey the number of young people who
feel content with their life and
optimistic about the future has been
declining for the last five years the
biggest concern for them is high
inflation and unemployment
Duro is one and she says she will vote
for main opposition leader Kmart who
represents six party opposition block
known as the table of six
Sean I want a better economy if we had
better future prospects here we wouldn't
want to go abroad migrants upset me yes
there should be Refugee Rights but some
measures should be taken more than half
of turkey's youth are reported to be
dissatisfied with the government and its
interference in their Lifestyles they're
worried about a lack of job
opportunities however bahadur a member
of the ruling party's youth group says
the opposite
I don't think the opposition has any
feasible plans to fix the economy many
engineering students these days have a
dream to work in National Industries
rather than going abroad I have no doubt
in my future
first-time voters will make up 12
percent of the elect rate in the
upcoming elections studies suggest many
Young Turks are not interested in
politics nearly half of those surveyed
are unhappy dissatisfied with their
schooling and they want to leave the
country however if they do cast their
ballots on May the 14th this group of
could influence turkey's political
future Turkish youth is widely regarded
as politically Savvy and whoever
addresses their concerns is likely be
able to secure their support
foreign